this week on quadriga
African Exodus who is to blame millions
of people in Africa are fleeing their
homeland trying to escape violence and
poverty they say they have no future in
the countries where they were born the
migrants risk their lives and sacrifice
everything they possess for the chance
to make it to Europe America and other
parts of the world African countries are
losing whole generations of young people
so who's responsible for the mass exodus
coming to you from Berlin quad Regan the
International debate your host this week
Melinda crane hello and welcome to a
quadriga the refugee crisis here in
Europe has been dominating the headlines
for weeks with much of the attention
focused on Syrians but the largest share
of those who are fleeing to the West are
Africans and we want to take a look this
week at their situation with three
African guests it's my pleasure to
welcome Richard chemist's he's a
journalist from South Sudan who came to
Germany for his studies and went on to
work for the German broadcaster Mitchell
Deutsche one folk he says many African
migrants are young and well-educated the
exodus will do lasting damage to the
economies of Africa and it's great to
have veía Tata with us she was born in
Cameroon and has lived in Germany for
many years she's an entrepreneur and the
editor-in-chief of Africa positive
magazine she says many policies of the
West and bad governments in some African
countries contribute to the exodus of
African youth and our third guest is
usman Shea who he's a journalist from
Nigeria who works on Deutsche Welle
Africa desk in Bonn and he says it's not
only corrupt leaders who are to blame
many people in Africa refuse to pay tax
they need to change their attitude
toward government so I have the honor to
moderate the OECD's Africa forum
yesterday here in Berlin and we heard
there one African leader and one
European leader after another telling us
the growth prospects in Africa haven't
looked so good in a long long time and
despite the fact that of course there
are conflicts in several countries the
fact is that the number of war victims
is also a good deal lower than it has
been in a long time so they Atatu
explain that paradox if you would please
Africa on an upswing and yet thousands
of people leaving
yeah the reality is the growth rate it
doesn't trickle down the profits don't
trickle down to the bottom of the
pyramid and why is that because you see
that most of the profits that are coming
in to the African countries are from the
extractive industries and in this
extractive industries they are only 1 or
2 percent employment taking place there
so it means the majority of the African
population is not being employed and
that's why you see a lot of them don't
have perspective without jobs they have
to go out to countries where they hope
that they have a better living standards
so that's the problem that we have that
we hear 10% grow 12% grew it to PR there
they get a lot of people don't have jobs
in these countries those I'll show you
it's common to talk about push and pull
factors in other words to ask are the
refugees fleeing from an unbearable
situation or are they fleeing to a
perceived promised land and that
distinction of course is relevant to a
lot of politicians here in Europe
because they ask whether they need to do
something to decrease the pull factor
how do you see it I think it is both
because there are some people that they
have to leave their country because
there's no way of living because of
conflict there are people who come here
because they want to make a good living
when I start to say for example in
Nigeria you have people who are a lot of
Nigeria in Europe but the Nigerian who
are in Europe are rich people compared
to the people in villages who live with
poverty who live with hunger
they don't have if you can be able to
pay that this traffic us money it when
you are rich but the poor people who
don't have what to eat to time a day
they cannot be able to pay these people
who are trafficking them they don't even
have the money to pay transport from
Niger
area Tunisia to Libya and come to Europe
so there are different people for
example if you have refugees from
countries where this is war where
there's a lot of drought like ninja
Republic they have a lot of drought but
I'm sure Nigeria have more refugees than
eg Republican Germany why because the
Nigerian who come here are not Nigerian
who are poor and Nigeria who are rich
but there are people who have conflict
when you look in some areas like in
Sudan and so on people don't have chance
of living they have to leave because
it's not because they don't have
business you are in the village doing
your farming but the famine is being
denied by war even in northeastern part
of Nigeria we have this so that's the
difference let's come back to that in
just a second I want to take a closer
look at some of those push factors that
some of the things that cause people to
leave but one more question about the
pull side Richard comments when we look
at the role of the media as I said the
poll question applies to politicians
should they be doing something more to
let people in Africa know that perhaps
the prospects here aren't as good as
they think but also to the media what
kind of picture are people in Africa
getting of the journey if they if they
decide to migrate of the journey itself
and also of the prospects that await
them here the likelihood for example
that they will in fact be given
permanent asylum yeah I mean that's
where the problem begins the picture
that we people in Africa get is a very
positive one and Europe is very rich
it's what they see Europe as God all
kind of facilities that in a human being
can you know think off and there's no
hungry in Europe it's an you get a
hospitals you get it functioning
infrastructures everything's correct
here everything's fine there's the peace
that they get down there nobody will
tell them that there is unemployment in
this country or in this continent nobody
will tell them that if you know you
don't have money you will starve and
nobody give you food nobody's sending
them that you know even if you're going
to adopt her you have to you know to pay
your you you you know your part
you know for treatment you have to buy
medicines but nobody tells them that
what about the journey how much
information do they have about how
dangerous this journey is how well to be
honest with you they have very very
little information of all that you see
they see the bigger picture the brighter
picture you know they see heaven and you
know to reach heaven you know you can do
whatever you want just to take the
journey to take the boat to reach that
destination but they there there is on
the way nobody cares now because some
people even say that hey I'm already
date so what can I just give it a try
interesting that all of you have
emphasized the fact that the refugees
are not necessarily the poorest and the
most downtrodden let's take a closer
look now at who's leaving and why this
man wants only one thing to get to
Europe like many Nigerians he's fleeing
poverty and Boko harem terrorism more
than 12,000 Nigerians have tried to make
it to Europe by sea this year alone
often with fatal results along with
South Africa Nigeria has Africa's most
powerful economy the country is rich in
natural resources but fails to exploit
its potential most Nigerians exist in
bitter poverty and the population is
growing dramatically the country has 170
million inhabitants Nigeria has massive
problems with pollution child labor and
religious strife it's a very explosive
mix
German and European migration policy is
based on making a distinction between
those who leave fleeing war and
persecution and those who leave as
economic migrants looking for a better
life so I'd like to talk a little bit
about the degree to which that
distinction holds we saw there somebody
who's leaving for a number of different
reasons perhaps I can ask bliss men to
get us started you are Nigerian perhaps
would you share with us why you left and
whether you think those categories of of
war and persecution on the one hand and
economic migration on the other really
hold up yes like I just said before in a
country like Nigeria those who are
coming for example in the report that
discussed that's the person leave where
Boko Haram East if you live in those
area you don't have we're of Libyan yes
I agree but the majority of Nigerian who
are in the West are not coming from the
northeastern part of the country where
they conflict is majority of the
Nigerian who pass through Libya through
this hardship who sacrificed their life
and not people who are coming from the
conflict and a Geryon who live in cities
who see their friends or their relative
who live in West already met it and they
already have a good houses they already
have a good of living they see that
people who have family in Europe they
send money every month or every week or
when there's any occasion they see them
they are wealthy people so these people
if we want to see whether there are
people who come from conflict or people
who come from rich I would say majority
of Nigerian who live to come here are
people who come because they want to
make a good living because they want to
get rich because the unsatisfied from
what they get but they are more poorer
people in the villages they are still in
the villages because they don't even
have money to pay to come to the cities
would you say that's right in your
experience as well
well yes somehow that's right but I
think
we have to look at these migration
policies from Europe while isn't it
possible that the Europeans create a
policy where African youth who are
educated have a chance to come legally
and work in Europe I mean we have I mean
we see Europeans can go legally and work
in different parts of the continents all
over the world so why can't you create
this opportunity for Africans to you
know so I think is is one way game we
Europeans we have the right to go
everywhere but what does don't have the
right to come to us so I think is
something that the African continent
also has you know to debate it out with
me the European governments and make
sure that we have legal ways of
migration because if we have this legal
waves of migration we are going to stop
you know the illegal can be luci you
cannot stop it completely in fact of
course Germany's Labor Minister has said
she would like to create I think twenty
five thousand visas for economic
migrants saying she believes that that
would limit the illegal flow do you
really think that's true though twenty
five thousand is really really really
small I mean we have to we have to face
the reality
anybody who has no perspective no matter
where he or she is living always tries
to get out to get a better living it
doesn't it doesn't matter from which
continent you are that's why you have
migration has always been there and it
would continue so I think the best way
is to make sure that the Europeans make
sure that the decisions they take here
in Europe all the decisions the German
government takes it doesn't affect the
living standards of other countries
negatively because as long as we have
profits from from our economic
activities back to the detriment of
different countries it's going to lead
to the migration of the youths from this
country let's come back to the role of
the market and the role of industry a
little bit later but perhaps first again
a closer look at some of the reasons
people have for leaving southern Sudan
certainly a country that you know very
well Richard come is how does this
balance between conflict and persecution
on the one hand and economic betterment
on the other play out there well
man we'll talk about sausage and the
main concern is of course the conflict
armed conflict and that's why they're
fleeing away right and but they don't
come to Europe these are very very
improvised people as my friend my friend
say who say it they can't even afford
and it you know a ticket to to to to to
leave that place to the nail to toe to
to leave your for example and take the
boat country or they kind of for that so
basically what what they do is - they
run in you know to the neighboring
countries and this world where they take
refuge and the economic aspect of that
doesn't play a very big role for
southern Sudanese at the moment we were
together at that Africa for him I
mentioned a bit earlier via Tata and
both of us heard one African leader
after another expressing distress about
the fact that so many Africans are
leaving the continent did that satisfy
you are they doing enough these leaders
to actually prevent the Exodus I don't
think so I mean all politicians are the
same you know because unfortunately they
are not doing their job rightly in some
African countries we have good
politicians who are trying to do the job
we're trying to tackle the challenges
that they face back home but to my
opinion in many African countries we
have politicians they don't just care
what the majority of the population is
going through and that's the problem in
most African countries because you know
the problem of ethnicity is a very big
problem that is how do you see an
obstacle to the development of many
African countries because when a leader
comes to power he doesn't think I'm the
leader of the whole nation he thinks I'm
the leader of this ethnical group we
have to stop that we have to go over
that we have to be responsible for the
for everybody with living in that
country and if we don't change that we
Africans nobody from outside is going to
help or solve our problems back home you
know because you have to have the
responsibility to care that
everybody in your country gets clean
water would hurt services with roads too
good it doesn't matter where they come
from it doesn't matter what language
they speak so I think that's something
that we have to start there and money is
not only the issue we need to change our
mindset in order to develop our
countries for governance is of course
often often cited as one of the major
push factors that are driving people to
leave Africa when African entrepreneur
decided that perhaps he could create an
incentive for good governance by by
awarding a prize for it and he only
discovered after he had established his
prize that it's not all that easy to
find a winner in 2007 former Mozambique
president Joakim Susanoo became the
first head of state to receive the
Ibrahim prize for excellence in African
leadership the prize has only been
awarded four times most recently in 2014
to ex-navy bein president if a kupuna
Pohamba there aren't many suitable
recipients many African heads of state
simply change their country's
constitutions to avoid having to leave
office when their time is up leading the
way is Teodoro Obiang in 1979 he
launched a push and took over Equatorial
Guinea he's been in power for 36 years
longer than any other African head of
state not far behind is Robert Mugabe
the authoritarian ruler of Zimbabwe is
90 years old and has been in office for
35 years they're just two examples of
power-hungry autocrats
lording over African countries
let's Michiko your opening statement
saying that people don't don't pay taxes
indicated that you think it's not only
the leaders to blame but also the
citizens they are a part of the bad
governance is that right yes because
most countries in Africa people look at
leaders people think that is the only
government can do for me I don't think
what I can offer the government here in
Europe everybody know that I must pay my
tax when I am working or if I have a car
this car must have a good license and
the problem in Africa the few companies
that it is compulsory for them to pay
tax this tax money is not going to the
government Treasury so that's the
problem people have that they think is
only the government I need hospital
I need route but I don't think wait what
is my own responsibility to give too so
that the government is able to do this
route for me but of course isn't it bad
elites who set the example there by
putting their own money abroad and Swiss
bank accounts and so on I know that your
new president in Nigeria or Nigeria's
new president was elected partly because
he was perceived to be immune to
corruption President Buhari however he
was quite authoritarian in his previous
time in power do you really expect that
he can turn things around in Nigeria
first of all I believe he will change
but before I go into debt I don't
believe he's authoritarian why do I say
I don't believe there are many head of
state in Nigeria past one who were more
authoritarian than him but it is not
reported for example the last President
Obasanjo who is a civilian government
during his Villa and he even arrests two
cities two villages were arrests down
completely nobody is talking about his
authoritarian so yes I agree there were
so many people in in Bucharest first
1000 who were persecuted but when they
were found not guilty in court they were
released and that's what happened even
in the West so the truth about yes he
was elected he doesn't have money and we
seen now I am NOT campaigning for
anybody but he has started to suit to
change good example is electricity
of the major problem of Nigeria is
electricity now in many city in villages
I was there myself I saw this
electricity people even have forgotten
putting foil in their generators to
light their houses even we even saw a
report of those who are selling
generators are complaining now their
market is went down so a lot of
industries shut down for example 60% of
industries in cities like canola or
Legos they shut down in the last 10
years because there's no electricity
most of the foreign companies that are
working in Nigeria they use generators
to foil their industry to foil their
machines because there is no National
Grid we thought that has changed and the
president already the economic itself
when he came Nigeria territory was so
empty he did not do any magic but we see
now Nigerian economic is getting up so
there is a lot of hope and expectation
if Africa will get people like him
definitely things will change because
he's just left 100 days and we are seen
some few changes become is one of the
absolute critical aspects of good
governance would be jobs Africa has a
tremendously young population it needs
millions and millions of new jobs every
year all across the continent why is it
so hard to create those jobs well the
people responsible job creation are the
people governing the country and you
know
Africa is underdeveloped right we need
infrastructures you cannot entrust an
individual businessman you know to
create roads or railways in you know the
in the whole country or the Hulk on the
continent it's the the task of the
government the task of those people in
power to create such infrastructures and
now for an infrastructure what you need
you need people who are able to you know
do something to to run machines for
example to pave places to you know to
drive tractors
and these are the young people was
supposed to be doing that but these
people have been trained you see and who
should put that scheme into place it's
the government it's not a private person
or the private business but is the
government first of all good governance
big topic in the development community
big topic at that forum we attended
yesterday
how much can development cooperation do
to put pressure on African leaders how
much can good governance be promoted
from outside it's difficult to promote
it from outside because I think it is a
problem in the society as I said before
the mindset of a society because when we
have societies in Africa where those who
do wrong those who acquire illicit money
are those whom the people admire then
that's a problem because we need honest
society we need society when we can
stand up and say you do the wrong thing
go in for it but in most of the society
those who really do the wrong things are
those who have been pushed up so we have
to change something in our mindset we
have to we have to make sure that those
who have the job you talked about needs
we have a lot of educating youth they
are not put and the position to take the
right decision they will take somebody
with in the ruling party who prefer to
take his brother who is not qualified to
go and do the job so we have to be
rational we have to stop those type of
behaviors that are contra productive to
our own nations you know so I think it's
very very important that we take the
decision
I'll show you many of the leaders at
yesterday's forum were saying look we
want to do better but the fact is the
deck is stacked against us the markets
the agricultural the whole agricultural
global economy is all working to the
benefit of major Western firms and
Western players there's little we can do
to solve our own problems would you
agree with that well I think Africa has
it is own problem but I think Africans
can do it why in the last TT about
twenty years back let president of
Burkina Faso say we don't need cotton
from anyway and I don't wear any clothes
as they've met in Burkina Faso so if in
the last 20 years he has this dream and
he knew that Britain has a can produce a
cotton that he don't need to buy clothes
outside then definitely they will do it
secondly we saw a lot of person in
Africa they just come to really get rich
we have to stop this because people just
come to reach not to rule not to people
come to power without any clan that if I
become a president of this country my
plan is this and that I want to achieve
this we didn't my time limit but people
come to get rich that is why we think
that the Europe companies are the only
one and the European companies their own
fault is any head of states come to
power he has the right to bring money
into Europe including Nigeria we saw how
many money from let Abacha that were
stuck in germany that way stuck in
Switzerland but Germany did not do
anything to set any corrupt penny any
corrupt dollars is not allowed to come
to my country then we will continue
seeing people like a badger because they
know they are being protected last word
Richard come is our title ask who's to
blame let's turn that around who can
change it we said development assistance
only partially change has to come from
within civil society in African
countries what can they do what do they
need well I mean they can also play a
you know a positive role trying to you
know detain the mindset of the people
but it's not only civil society every
part each and everybody in Africa has
got a role to play not only about the
government the civil society educated
class even the farmer but you know they
have to change a mindset you know to
think about put the continent first and
then I'm afraid we have to leave it
right there
thanks for joining us thanks to you out
there for tuning in see you soon
you